balèze surtout à 7 heures du matin dans
le milieu du rock plutôt leur à laquelle
on se couche que celle où on se lève
mais quand on démarre une carrière il
faut être prêt à ce genre de sacrifices
invité pour la première fois au
printemps de bourges les iphone iphone
se plie aux règles imposées aux artistes
de la scène découverte pour laisser la
place aux têtes d'affiché le square les
jeunes talents sont programmés entre 12h
et 15h
ce qui implique des préparatifs et
surtout une balance au petit matin sans
passer par la case petit déj
au moment où les femmes de ménage
commence elle aussi leur journée en
train de manger même il est quand même
19 6 3 elle est belle la télé française
en classe originaire de nice les iphone
iphone n'ont pas encore de maison de
disque mais ils ont un manager habitué
du festival et qui connaît à
l'importance de ce rendez vous très
spécifiques
il faut avoir
cette capacité aussi à sociabiliser en
dehors du temps de concert mais au-delà
de ça la force de pense des groupes à
bourges qui réussit sa bouche c'est
aussi d'être disponible avant et après
pour la rencontre justement et du public
et des médias et des professionnels du
secteur les professionnels producteurs
tourneurs directeur artistique
programmateurs de salles
ils sont plus de 1800 présent à bourges
pour faire leur marché sur ou le premier
gros festivals de la nuit moi je mets un
point d'honneur avant le programme un
groupe à le voir sur scène parce qu'un
disque les vidéos
c'est pas suffisant on va voir le celi
est une chose mais les voir sur scène
c'est vrai que c'est nettement mieux et
en plus les voir sur scène avec du
public
et là ils sont ici c'est pas mal le
professait long car il ya le côté
un autre côté on compte une potée
critique et qui est plus pointu que le
grand public et ça permet de vaduz de te
suicider sur la valeur du groupe
je maquille et tiens je fais un plan on
fait un plan du torse ou je te mets le
truc et après on est bon parce que là je
sais que je suis un peu stressé non en
fait de professionnels donc ne viennent
pas ici vraiment pour faire la fête et
du pot faut garder que j'ai pour toi je
peux te permettre de regarder le show et
je sais pas l'énergie alors que le
public n'est pas forcément hyper réactif
à
pas bloqué par l'enjeu les hyphen hyphen
ont livré une prestation à la hauteur de
leur réputation scénique est naissante
au point d'arriver a secoué le public au
moins dans les premiers rangs
mais pour les découvertes à peine le
temps de se chauffer qu'il faut déjà
s'arrêter
la durée du concert est limitée à une
demi-heure maximum et après il faut
assurer la vente et le service après
vente
c'est bien allez je continue à aller je
continue à tuer me donne une petite
photo c'est le quart aile entière
cg mon collègue qui m'a fait un méchant
belge et m'adapter dans le septième jeu
7/6 ya pas mal du niveau qui se sont
donnés on ira vite en fait de ton tout
le but de ce concert était 2 de
conquérir un public et de concourir le
milieu professionnel alors on a je pense
à mon à mon sens on a réussi sa les
beaux mais ravi de revenir
il était là il ya un an était en
découvertes on faisait tout pour tout ce
qui était possible pour se faire
remarquer on avait des habits brillant
tout ça et maintenant on est dans la
case la case vrai concert
le printemps de bourges peut
véritablement lancer une carrière
professionnelle
françois hémery atlas mountains sont
bien placés pour le savoir il y a un nom
elle était la découverte de la région
poitou charentes
cette année ils sont revenus sur une
grande scène à la même affiche que
camille et dominique a je me souviens
d'un tourneur et l art à bourges l'an
dernier avec nous et à la fin du
week-end nous on dire je pense qu'on a
au moins une dizaine de concerts prévus
grâce au concert que vous avez fait
business is business la loi du marché et
loi de la jungle où on est assez loin de
l'esprit des premiers printemps un
festival créé au départ pour soutenir la
chanson française contestataires en un
grand attachement ferme sur scène
beaucoup d'artistes continue à tenir un
discours radical a critiqué la société
de consommation mais côté coulisses ils
doivent bien composer avec un milieu
professionnel dont ils ont besoin a
expliqué qu'ils n'ont pas payé leur
place qu'il faut applaudir tous et du
spectacle dans l'équipe on sait qu'à un
public d'avant premières au machin
public a pas payé sa place il s'est pas
investi pour venir dont ils viennent en
plus pour épier tout
s'il faut les seconds eux mais après
plus pour assurer public seul artiste de
la région centre présents dans la
sélection des découvertes et sam tâches
etc slameur converti au rap est prêt à
quelques compromis mais pas trop quand
même
il ya un côté voir au tapin
ma chance c'est sûr on vient aussi là
pour seulement d'après ya se vendre et
biz
et puis vent de se rendre n'importe
comment
tous aiment le faire dignement la
musique voitures échouées rsa 30 piges
au sujet des vénale ça serait vu avant
peut-être ça faut bien admettre que ce à
un moment donné si tu veux rendre les
choses plus sérieuses ça devient aussi
un business il faut commencer à se
professionnaliser on en n'est pas 3d
budget de singer on est ric-rac en tout
de même pour se payer la bouffe pour la
semaine un faut pas se leurrer mais par
contre vous pouvez essayer de voir ça
comme un business
c'est bien ici parce que c'est le cas on
peut le voir comme un business sans que
ça devienne la foire à la connerie
archives car j'ai trop de respect pour
l'utopie que jette pas toi là pour lui
coller mes initiales alors qu'elle a
féminin karachi car je vante au jour le
jour quand je fais mes courses mais
toujours pas dans le cinquième pour
imprimer ses affiches sortir un disque
et préparer quelques concerts sam tâche
a tout de même reçu une aide des
collectivités locales 3400 euros une
somme pas encore suffisante pour qu'on
puisse considérer qu'il a vendu son âme
je vois des gens qui se disent under
grande machin d'alors ils financent leur
céder en autoprod du mois ils font tout
et moi aussi
toute la semaine ils se vendent au grand
capital en allant go ces machins et puis
le week-end ils vont chanter wesh wesh
on est militant machin à 7,8 je trouve
ça un peu facile moi je prends le risque
date au rsa ne pas avoir de thunes et
tout donner pour ma musique
d'autres artistes de la scène
découvertes sont déjà dans des
structures très professionnelle comme
christine and queens le projet solo
d'une jeune parisienne un bourge un
célèbre magasin culturel lui a proposé
d'organiser un petit spectacle la veille
du vrai concert au milieu des
présentoirs et d'un public de curieux
c'est
aïe
bonjour tu t'appelles comment
génial john la jeunesse l'abri
on a d'abord dû
déjà repéré par le milieu depuis
quelques temps grâce à un passage dans
taratata et une participation au mois de
mars à la tournée des femmes s'en mêlent
christine and the queen vient tabour
dans l'espoir de développer encore un
peu plus son projet aujourd'hui c'est on
y ait beaucoup de projets en
développement qui sont à la fois
médiatisé en même temps qui reste aussi
sans beaucoup de moyens sûrs que moi je
dirais pas non à quelques moyens
supplémentaires et à des rencontres
supplémentaires mais c'est vrai que j'ai
eu un bon mois de mars avant le
printemps de bourges eu ce qui fait que
j'arrive déjà un petit peu armés
m
seul sur scène avec son ordinateur
christine and the queen c'était très
entouré à l'issue de son concert
notamment par les responsables de
maisons de disques plusieurs éditeurs
indépendants et médor s'intéresse à elle
parmi eux alan gac directeur d'un des
plus gros labels indépendants
when clicked on forcément
c'est un peu stressant même moment ont
plutôt qui passe et vous avez entendu ça
j'ai entendu je trouve une autre
solution
je suis très clair
c'est quelqu'un avec qui on aimerait
effectivement travailler c'est une
artiste qui nous intéresse beaucoup
depuis quelques mois déjà
donc
voilà nous sommes en discussion avec
elle en espérant pouvoir avoir la chance
de travailler avec elle sans discussion
c'est en discussion
après je suis à d'autres les ont dit ce
qu'ils s'intéressent à elle donc il ya
des choix à faire aider
voilà une fois presque d'être est allé
voilà on discutera en attendant le choix
et la signature du contrat ce passage à
bourges lui permet déjà de repartir avec
une proposition concrète
une invitation aux berlines mieux et
quick un grand festival allemand dont le
directeur a été séduit
moi je suis rentré c'est de faire ni
lien aussi entre les artistes berlinois
et des artistes de
internationaux en guyane le groupe
berlinois qui s'appelle line ils sont
comparables à christine et combinations
entre les deux artistes ça serait génial
au moins ça parfois je te vois vraiment
comme ça écoutez je sais pas du tout
quand je les trouvais très silencieux et
du coup je savais pas que j'étais
déstabilisé nantais
il ya des contacts en fait les gens qui
viennent me voir après
je te donne alors qu arte pour deux
de les rappeler j'ai même j'ai même
quelqu'un de the voice qui m'a demandé
de le rappeler
cinq minutes pardon ça me fait juste
rigolé l'émission sur tf1
bonjour festival des contacts inattendue
la journée de christina bourges va se
conclure sur un autre événement
inattendu
les organisateurs lui ont demandé
d'assister à la conférence de presse de
fin de printemps ou été remis deux prix
attribués à des artistes qui ont séduit
un jury de professionnels le coup de
coeur revient à christine and queens
alors on va faire comme à cannes aux
molières et tout ça vous allez nous dire
un petit mot
j'étais déjà très heureuse d'être
accueilli au printemps de bourges pour
un jeune artiste c'est toujours une
étape assez stressante mais en même
temps très agréable aussi et vous êtes
tous très beau en fait avec vos blancs
bleus fluorescents voit la première
lauréate du prix coup de coeur du
printemps de bourges
christine and the queen c'est déjà bien
lancée pour l'année 2012 où on devrait
la revoir sur quelques gros festivals
comme les francofolies et ce n'est
peut-être qu'un début